Professor Amy
Hungerford: My first lecture
on The Known World
focused on the question of
knowledge and the problems of
knowledge that the text raises
for us throughout,
both at the formal level and at
the thematic level.
So, I ended up with a reading
of the account of the Broussard
trial and how more and more
detailed knowledge comes to us
through the voice of the
narrator,
and we're really left with that
question: where does that
knowledge come from?
Now, I suggested in the first
lecture that my second lecture
was going to be about an equally
abstract subject,
and that is:
how can anything exist in the
world?
I'm going to get to that about
in the middle of the lecture,
beginning from this question,
though, where we ended last
time, about the Broussard trial
and the problem of knowledge,
where knowledge comes from.
If we look a little bit earlier
in the passage about the
Broussard trial on 171,
172, you find what I think is
quite a striking model for the
very problem of this novel as a
whole.
And this is when Skiffington is
trying to write an account of
Broussard's crime,
and here it is on the bottom of
171.
He's having trouble filling out
this form.
Skiffington picked up the
list of questions.
Now he would have to start all
over again.
Nature of the alleged crime.
Are there witnesses to the
alleged crime?
Can such witnesses be
believed?
So, the problem of evidence and
the problem of whether witnesses
are to be trusted,
the problem of enumerating a
crime, these are all problems
that the novel as a whole takes
up for the crime of slavery.
So, we can think of the novel
itself as a version of
Skiffington's report.
Now, it's important that
Skiffington has such a problem
writing it.
The very difficulty of writing
is thematized over and over and
over again, not just in moments
like this where it's actually
talking about writing,
but, I'm going to argue,
in a number of ways that are
much more subtle.
And to show you one of them,
I want to look on 192 with you.
This is the scene where
Stamford, the slave,
is trying to remember the names
of his parents,
and this is how he does it.
This is the middle of 192.
He closed his eyes and
took his parents in his hands
and put them all about the
plantation where he had last
seen them,
his mother in his left hand and
his father in his right hand.
But that did not feel right,
and so he put his father in his
left hand and his mother in his
right hand, and that felt
better.
He set them outside the
smokehouse, which had a hole in
the roof in the back.
"Hants come down that hole and
take you to the devil," an older
boy had once told him.
Stamford was five,
and it had not been long since
his parents had been sold
away.
And you get more of the story,
and he finally comes to
remember the parents' names,
his parents' names.
Why does he take them in these
specific hands,
his father in his right hand
and his mother in his left;
"that did not feel right so he
put his father in his left and
his mother in the right"?
I would argue that this is for
two reasons: a figure of Jones'
own writing, first of all in the
obvious sense that it's an act
of recovery,
of recovering a past that needs
to be imagined,
or somehow entered into,
not through rational thought,
but through an imaginative act.
So, that's one reason that
Stamford in this moment is a
double of Jones.
But the other reason is this
"handedness" that's noted.
I'm going to tell you,
throughout the lecture,
a few things about Jones' life
and his work outside of this
novel,
and so here's the first piece
of that story.
Edward P.
Jones was the son of a very
poor single mother living in
D.C.
He had a younger brother who
was mentally disabled who had to
be given away to an institution
because the mother could not
support him.
Jones' mother was illiterate.
So, here is someone writing
this novel, and his background
is an illiterate mother.
This matters enormously to him.
He, in his first story
collection, has a story called
(I think it's called) "First
Day,"
where he tells the story of a
young girl going off to school
for the first time,
holding the hand of her
illiterate mother.
Jones reveres his mother.
When he talks about her,
it's with incredible reverence
and love.
Jones sees his mother very much
as a source of his writing.
So, here's that first tension
in the act of writing,
that here is a writer who takes
as his source,
spiritual source,
an illiterate woman.
That's why the mother has to go
in his right hand in this scene.
Now, of course,
not everybody writes with their
right hand, but I think no
matter whether Jones is right or
left handed--and I thank Andy
Heisel for pointing out,
our wonderful TA Andy Heisel,
for pointing out that in the
photograph of Jones he is
wearing his watch on his left
hand,
and so this would suggest that
he is, perhaps,
right handed.
But even if we didn't want to
rely--Oh, Neil,
you're going to give me
trouble--even if you did not
want to rely on that little
piece of evidence,
we can say that in the cultural
vocabulary of handedness the
dominant hand is the right hand
for writing.
So, I would say that whenever
you see right-handedness or
left-to-right movement,
Jones is meditating on and
figuring the act of writing,
and I'm going to show you some
more examples 'cause it's quite
striking.
It's subtle and strange,
but quite striking.
So, the mother has to go in the
right hand because she is the
source of inspiration.
The father--Jones'
father--was very distant.
He only met him when he was
much older, and he was not
really a part of Jones' life at
all.
It really revolved around his
mother.
So, if writing is undermined by
the shadow of illiteracy for
Jones, it's undermined in other
ways,
too, and I want to look at one
of those stranger episodes.
This is on 142,143.
This is the story of how Henry
began to court Caldonia at Fern
Elston's dinner table,
and this is a very detailed
scene.
This is in the middle of 142.
He's telling Caldonia that she
needs to look up when she rides
her horse.
He took the pepper shaker
in his right hand,
extended his arm before him,
and moved the arm from right to
left.
Everyone at the table was now
watching him.
The hand with the shaker moved
smoothly, gracefully,
from the right to the left.
"That's how everybody else
rides," Henry said,
"me and everybody else."
Henry put the pepper shaker in
his left hand,
tipped it, and moved his arm
less gracefully from the left to
the right.
As it moved pepper poured out
of the shaker onto Fern's white
tablecloth.
He said, "I'm sorry to say
this, but that's how you ride."
Henry did this with the shaker
several times.
Going from right to left,
the pepper shaker was upright,
but going from left to right
the pepper flowed down.
Fern thought there was
something rather sad about the
pepper falling and it was all
the sadder because it really
didn't have to be that way.
She said to Anderson,
the pamphleteer from Canada,
this was his clumsy way of
telling Caldonia she was losing
something by not looking
up.
How odd, that insistence on the
movement left to right,
right to left.
It figures Henry's mixed-up
relation to both language and
the act of creation.
It's mixed up,
because when he is moving in
the direction that text is read
and written,
left to right,
he's using his left hand,
and the correlative of that
left handedness of his relation
to language is in the dialect.
He doesn't speak correctly in
Fern Elston's house no matter
how hard she tries to teach him.
So, he is clumsy,
not only in spilling pepper on
the table, but also in not being
able to speak proper English.
But the other thing about that
movement is that when it goes
left to right pepper spills on
the table.
This is an image of ink flowing
out of a pen--it is black on the
white tablecloth--and it's an
image for language in jeopardy
because of course it's dust;
it's powder;
it will never cohere;
it's the sign of his uncouth
table manners.
So, it's never going to be a
redemptive medium for him,
and it's represented by this
pepper that then he can scrape
into a little pile.
This is the fragmentation
of language in its very literal
sense.
There are other examples of
this, on 189 when you get the
first account of the frozen dog
that Calvin is so interested in,
in the photograph from New York.
Once again, direction is
carefully noted.
In the front yard,
alone, was a dog looking off to
the right.
The dog was standing,
its tail sticking straight out
as if ready to go at the first
word from someone on the porch.
[And I'm going to skip down.]
He had a very tiny hope that
when he got to New York he might
be able to find the house and
those people and that dog and
learn what had transfixed him.
There was a whole world off to
the right that the photograph
had not captured.
"Off to the right" is the
direction of flowing narrative,
a world, a possible world that
his imagination is drawn to,
and it's a visual image of the
imagination and its seduction.
But because of this obsessive
direction noting,
I would read it as a textual
imagination, that there's a
narrative off to the right.
And you can see that Jones'
novel works this way.
There is always a narrative
proximate to wherever you are,
a little narrative that arises
from the next character who
shows up on the road,
and you'll get that narrative.
So, this is just one of those
that doesn't quite get
articulated, but Calvin can
imagine that it's there;
he can see, as if he can see
the form of the novel that Jones
is writing.
And then there are just
even tinier ones.
On 162, this is John
Skiffington sitting and reading
the Bible after visiting Clara's
house.
"Skiffington looked up and
followed a male cardinal as it
flew from the left to right and
settled in one of the peach
trees."
They're all over the place once
you start noticing them,
so I think this is why:
that it's a constant meditation
among the multiplying versions
of meditations on the
composition of this novel within
the novel.
So, we'll get to some others.
The problem is that the written
word is always threatened.
So, if writing has all this
static that surrounds it,
it also has some more direct
and aggressive enemies,
and on 375 you see one version
of that.
This is the account of Barnum
Kinsey's grave marker that his
son makes after they leave
Manchester County and he dies.
This is at the bottom of 374.
Matthew stayed up all the
night before he was
buried--[this is Kinsey's son]
putting his father's history on
a wooden tombstone.
He began with his father's name
on the first line,
and on the next he put the
years of the father's coming and
going,
then all of the things he knew
his father had been.
[And it then lists this whole
set of things.]
The boy filled up the whole
piece of wood,
and at the end of the last line
he put a period.
His father's grave would
remain, but the wooden marker
would not last out the
year.
Text is simply fragile,
as a material object,
so that's what this scene tells
us, in a poignant way.
But, of course,
the most poignant example of
this is when Augustus's free
papers are eaten by Travis.
So, the real terror of the
written word comes in that
scene.
Now the terror is of course
that it's an exercise of
power--arbitrary,
violent.
It will end in Augustus' death
back in slavery.
There are lots of ways of
imagining what the terror is.
I'm going to go into some of
them, but this is the sign of
it, that even though Augustus
has memorized every word of his
free papers--remember,
we're told that he has them
read to him every day for a
month.
He's illiterate.
He has them read to him every
day for a month until he has
them totally memorized after he
gets his freedom--even though
those words will exist forever
in Augustus' mind,
his freedom is nowhere,
once the written word is gone.
So, this is my question:
How can something exist in the
world?
Here, the ultimate thing to
which that question applies is
freedom.
How can freedom exist?
What makes freedom exist?
Well, in the law,
those free papers make freedom
exist for Augustus,
but the law cannot guarantee
that freedom exists when the
physical artifact of the text is
gone.
That's how weak writing is.
It seems to be everything.
This is something that Mildred
understood quite early on.
On 113, when she and Augustus
are worried about Henry hanging
out with Robbins,
she says, in suggesting that
it's okay to let Henry go about
with William Robbins,
"'Them free papers he carry
with him all over the place
don't carry enough freedom,'
she said to her husband,
'with slavery behind him.'"
She wanted her son to go about
and see what had always been
denied him, so she wants the
world to be a big place for him.
She sees that freedom is
something much more than those
papers, but the problem is that
freedom cannot be without them,
and that once they're gone,
it is gone too.
So, that is one of the
threats that is associated with
writing, but there are more of
them.
On 311 and 312,
one danger is that,
in the effort to write justice
in law, it's simply ineffective.
So, here is the story we get of
Skiffington trying to write up
this crime, the crime of selling
Augustus, a free man,
back into slavery.
This is on 312.
He's been in contact with a man
named Sanderson in,
I think he's in Georgia.
He got a letter from
Sanderson three days after that.
The crime had indeed been
committed, he wrote,
and Sanderson included material
he had copied from books saying
so.
So, Skiffington wasn't sure
whether it was really a crime.
Somehow he began to get
confused, and you can see that
confusion--I won't read it--on
the prior page,
on 311 in the middle of the
page.
So, when Skiffington once again
starts writing up the crime,
he becomes confused.
Did he really have a crime to
describe?
He gets confirmation that he
does.
But Skiffington heard
from Richmond [yes,
it's a letter from Richmond]
again four days later,
in handwriting he did not
recognize.
Graciela Sanderson let him know
that her husband,
Harry, was dead and that she
was now charged with keeping up
his correspondence.
He read the eight-page letter
twice, but he found nothing in
it about what Virginia was doing
about the crime of selling free
Negroes.
The widow told him about her
husband, how she had met him
when he vacationed in Italy,
how he had wooed her,
brought her to America after
their wedding and made her a
happy woman in Richmond,
" where the governor is in
residence."
[And then she closes with
comments about the weather.]
So, the law's effort to deliver
justice through the writing of a
crime, the documenting of a
crime,
is displaced by a woman's
effort to recover her lost
husband by telling that story.
So, there are competing claims
on language in this scene:
the widow's and Skiffington's,
and more distantly Augustus'
and Mildred's.
None of these claims are
adjudicated in any kind of way
that puts one above the other,
and Skiffington's weakness,
of course, is that he will
never seek to right that
balance.
He resigns himself to the
weakness of writing.
More chillingly,
and I think more
complicatingly,
writing also carries the risk
of reinstating the master-slave
relationship,
and I think it does this by
direct reference back to Jones
himself.
If you read slowly through the
scene of Augustus being sold
back into slavery,
it's quite striking the way
contingency or happenstance
plays a part in the scene.
So, after Travis has eaten
Augustus' papers--this is at the
very bottom of 212--"a wagon
twice as large as Augustus' came
up to the four men.
Driving it was a large black
man, and beside him a much
smaller white man."
And Travis teases Darcy,
the slave trader,
about how he's never known the
time in his life,
but suddenly here he is at
exactly the right time.
Then he later says--as he's
formulating the idea of selling
Augustus to Darcy,
he says--"God works in
mysterious ways.
This ain't exactly what I had
in mind when I stopped this
nigger but this here will do
just the same."
Who made that wagon appear?
Why does that wagon appear?
Jones made that wagon appear.
What we're given is not a
fiction about Travis intending
to sell Augustus back into
slavery, but what we're given
instead is a surprise on the
road.
Who makes that surprise appear?
Only one person,
the person in charge of making
the narrative.
So, the problem with
writing is not just that it's
shadowed by the fact of
illiteracy.
It's not just that it's
vulnerable to physical decay.
It's not just that it's weak
and it can't make anything exist
in law.
It's not just that it's
demanded by multiple people for
different purposes that come to
cancel each other out.
It's that by writing,
by taking on that quality of
masterfulness,
you begin to be complicit in
the very crime that you're
describing.
The imagery of God looking down
on his creation is everywhere in
this novel,
and it's applied to all kinds
of characters,
including Henry,
who thinks that he will look
down on his slaves the way God
looks down on his creation from
heaven.
That position of mastery and
that geographic remove of being
above your subject is associated
with the slave-master,
but it's associated very much
with Jones.
And I'll come back to this in a
minute when I talk about the
tapestry, because of course the
tapestry at the end of the
novel--Alice's tapestry--is the
most dramatic figure for the
whole novel.
There are lots of figures for
the novel, including the map of
the "known world,"
but foremost that tapestry at
the end which mimics the novel
in every way.
Even that has the perspective
of little figures looking up,
so it even puts Alice in that
masterful position,
or indeed anyone who looks upon
that tapestry.
So, if writing is so weak,
if it entails such terror,
are we given any alternative
for creative durability?
And I think we are,
in the plastic arts.
Now, I'm sure you've noticed
how much carving goes on in the
book, not just because Augustus
is a woodworker,
but because Elias carves for
Celeste;
that's his first act of love.
And, if you read Jones'
stories, this is rampant in his
stories.
He has carvers everywhere and
various kinds of workers in
plastic arts.
Alice is another example
working in textiles,
clay, paint,
some amalgamation of sculpture
and painting.
On 279 the two arts,
the verbal art and woodworking,
are put in competition with one
another,
or in juxtaposition with one
another, and I think you see who
has the upper hand here.
This is an account of
Skiffington's bookcase,
which Augustus made.
In Winifred and John
Skiffington's parlor there was a
wondrous-looking bookcase,
lovely oak, a lion's growling
face at each edge of the top
ends, three shelves,
a secondhand item made by
Augustus Townsend not long after
Augustus bought his freedom.
He had first thought he would
keep it for himself and the
family he would buy out of
slavery, though none of them
could read, then.
He and Mildred would never
learn to read.
[There is that shadow of
illiteracy.
Our attention is called to it
the minute the books are
mentioned.]
He would keep it as a kind of
symbol for his determination to
get them,
but then he realized that what
he could get for the bookcase
would bring his wife and child
closer to him so he put a price
on it,
fifteen dollars.
It had been originally sold to
a man of two slaves who lost his
sight, [another risk to reading:
you can go blind]
and so,
as he told Skiffington,
lost his hunger and thirst for
books.
Skiffington bought it for five
dollars.
Augustus' art is durable.
It can be passed from person to
person, and it maintains its
figurative power.
It's important that all of his
work is figurative.
It suggests narrative,
and so it's aligned with Jones'
art, in that way,
but it is not subject to the
vulnerability of text,
and here in this bookcase you
see the vulnerability of text
set right next to the wondrous
durability of the bookcase.
There are other examples.
When Rita is discovered in the
box of walking sticks,
when she is sent in a box out
of slavery to New York,
she hands the boy who is
looking down at her the walking
stick with Adam and Eve and all
their generations.
It's as if in that act Rita's
freedom is instantiated,
that she and all her
descendants emerge into this new
world,
and that that is a kind of gift
to the family that takes them
in, in the North.
So, it has a very evocative
narrative power that doesn't
depend on people's being able to
read it,
and we're told in that scene
that the boy receives it as if
this is what he had been waiting
for all along,
suggests a perfect receptivity,
no going blind here,
perfect receptivity.
There is also on 219 one of
Augustus' chairs that I think is
worth looking at.
This is when Travis is
reflecting on,
or we are being told about,
how Travis first came to know
Augustus.
He had first come to know
Augustus Townsend many years ago
through a chair Augustus had
made for a white man in the town
of Manchester.
The man weighed more than four
hundred pounds.
[And then I'm skipping down.]
In the man's parlor was
Augustus' chair,
plain,
not even painted,
but smooth to the touch,
and when the man sat in it the
chair did not complain,
not one squeak.
It just held up and did its
job, waiting for the man to put
on another three hundred pounds.
Travis examined the chair,
looked all about it trying to
discover its secret.
The chair gave nothing.
It was a very good chair.
It was a chair worth
stealing.
The chair gave nothing.
Well, it gave nothing in terms
of knowledge to Travis.
It would not give up its secret
of durability,
and that's, in a way,
what makes it durable,
that it can hide the essence of
itself, keep it to itself.
It takes the weight without one
squeak.
Its very silence is what marks
its invulnerability.
It's also what enrages a man
like Travis.
So, the novel sets up a
competing set of art forms,
carving foremost among them,
against the art form of
language.
The tapestry at the end answers
one of our questions from the
first lecture,
which is who knows the known
world, known by whom?
What we come to find out is
that Alice, although she seemed
insane, is the one who knows
Manchester County.
She has walked all over it,
in the freedom carved out by
her insanity.
One thing that's interesting
about Alice is that she--despite
her insanity,
seeming insanity--is the one
most in control of her language.
She is the most successful
storyteller in this novel.
So, if you think of other
alternatives,
Moses--He tells Caldonia
stories that finally fail to
persuade her imagination that
any slave she owns could be
free.
We're told explicitly,
as Calvin tries to persuade her
at the end of the novel,
that it's her failure of
imagination that keeps her from
emancipating her slaves after
Henry's death.
Despite all of Moses' stories,
she still cannot see him,
or anyone else,
as a free person.
So, Moses' storytelling is
a complete failure in this way,
but Alice's storytelling about
the mule that kicked her in the
head,
we find that out early in the
novel that the story about
her--that's why she is said to
be crazy we're told--so vivid,
so sad, that everybody believed
it.
The very control she has over
her crazy chants is what
persuades the whole world around
her that she is not worth
bothering with,
as she wanders around the roads
with impunity.
It also gives her occasion to
mock the master,
the structure of slavery,
the patrollers,
and she can do it with
impunity, as well.
So, she has a freedom of mind
as well as a freedom of movement
that nobody else in the novel
has who is a slave.
So, she is doubly marked as an
artist in language and in the
plastic arts,
but she is--importantly,
I think--not a writer.
You'll note,
if you look at 384,385,
where the tapestry is
described, there is still some
whiff of that fragility.
And I see that in the
admonition that is hung next to
the tapestry and that Priscilla
repeats when Calvin reaches out
to touch it.
She says, "Please do not touch."
There is that sense that this
is still something that needs to
be protected.
Now, why the terror?
Why the fragility?
Well, I think this has a lot to
do with how this novel was
composed.
Edward P.
Jones wrote his first book of
short stories in the 1990s,
in the early '90s.
I can't remember the date
exactly.
And it was very successful,
but not successful enough to
support him, so he worked as an
editor at a journal called
Tax Notes.
It was a journal of tax law,
scintillating.
Jones was working there,
and I'm going to tell you a
story, now, that he tells in
some of his interviews,
but I heard first from his
agent, a guy named Eric
Simonoff, who I had up to visit
one of my classes when we were
studying this novel.
Eric says that he heard from
Edward that Edward had this idea
for a novel about a black slave
owner but he said,
"Don't tell anyone.
This is a stealable idea."
So Eric, when he went down to
D.C., would occasionally stop in
over the years and see Edward
and he'd say,
"Well, how's the novel going?"
Didn't seem to be much on
paper, and time passed,
ten years or so,
and Eric thought,
"I'm not sure if this novel's
ever going to get written."
In the meantime Jones had
amassed about a hundred and
twenty five books of history of
the period that he is working
in,
in the novel,
because he felt that in order
to write a novel like this he
really needed to master that
history.
It was very intimidating to
him, though, so that--combined
with his Tax Notes
job--he had about twelve pages
written.
So, he went on vacation after a
long time.
He hadn't had a vacation.
He had about a six-week
vacation, and he finally got a
start, and one of the ways that
he got himself to start was he
decided that he was going to
forget about the history;
he was going to make it all up.
So, all the historical
sources-- if you read the back
of the book you will know
this--all the historical sources
are fictional,
here.
The census reports,
every detail is fictional,
so that was his first move.
Then he got laid off from
Tax Notes right after
this vacation.
Edward P.
Jones then wrote this novel in
three months,
and Eric says that it became
clear to him over the years that
Jones had in fact memorized
entire chapters of what became
this novel.
It was all in his head,
all the words in their order,
and so when he had the time and
when he freed himself from the
obligation to history,
out it came.
I think this says a lot
about the images of writing that
you see all over the novel.
Imagine the kind of terror that
you would feel,
knowing that you had all this
in your mind and knowing also
that it didn't yet exist on
paper,
that you had only twelve pages.
Maybe if you're writing papers
now, you feel this terror of the
blank page.
It's possible.
That's a real terror for a
writer.
Combine that with the shadow of
illiteracy, the feeling of
possible betrayal,
for a son to be a writer when
his beloved mother had no access
to the written word.
This is a very vexed,
complex psychological
relationship that I would
suggest--my guess is--that has a
lot to do with how he imagines
the relative fragility and the
relative power of fiction versus
these other arts.
So, Jones models his narrative
on those other arts in an effort
to solve the problems that are
presented by the terror of the
written word's fragility,
its very uneasy relation to
existence.
Does a novel exist?
Does it not?
And I think there is,
actually, even a figure for
Jones in a particular character,
one of these tiny characters,
on 343.
This is a young man with a
wonderfully complicated mind.
Wilson had learned a
great deal at that university,
and his mind would have
contained even more,
but well in to his second year
the cadavers began to talk to
Wilson and what they said made
far more sense than what his
professors were saying.
The professors,
being gods, did not like to
share their heaven with anyone
dead or alive,
and they sent the young man
home in the middle of his second
year.
Here you see a figure for
someone whose imagination is so
powerful that it makes the dead
talk,
and think back again to the
image of Stamford finding--by
placing the image of his parents
all over the mansion,
all over the
plantation--finding their names.
That's a little like talking to
cadavers.
They are dead, those parents.
It verges on insanity.
This is another problem with
the mode of composition,
that a mind this powerfully
populated by an alternate
reality comes to look insane,
and I think this is another
reason why Alice is what she is
as a character.
If she is going to be one of
the major doubles for Jones,
her insanity is part of that
picture.
We can think of it as a willed
insanity, but it has the residue
of doubt about it.
Maybe she really is insane to
some degree.
Is there a sharp line between
an imagination that can produce
a narrative so thoroughly
populated as this one and a mind
that sees cadavers talking to
you?
Another thing that is
remarkable about Jones'
work--and this relates back to
what I was saying about
postmodernism and grand
narrative last time--Jones' work
is seemingly very fragmented.
There are lots and lots of
narratives, but they don't all
come together in one narrative,
so it seems fragmented,
and when you start to read it,
it looks disorienting.
If you read his stories,
you will see that all of the
stories are interconnected back
to the novel,
to Jones' life.
So, for instance in All Aunt
Hagar's Children,
his most recent story
collection,
and I think it came out in
2007, there is a woman who has a
walking stick that is clearly
made by Augustus,
in the twentieth century.
What I was saying about the
durability of the plastic arts
is imagined in that quality of
his fiction.
These objects of carving turn
up throughout his stories.
Also, people are related to
each other in separate stories.
They're related to people in
this novel.
The title of this novel appears
in a story called "Tapestry" in
All Aunt Hagar's Children.
He is obsessive about
putting the locations of all the
places that he lived in D.C.
into his stories perfectly
accurately.
When an editor at The New
Yorker tried to get him to
change one of these descriptions
and the address,
in one of the stories that he
submitted for the magazine,
he was very resistant.
He finally changed it for
The New Yorker,
but when it went into the
story collection it went back,
because he wanted it to be
absolutely accurate to what it
was like when he lived there,
what it actually looks like on
that corner in D.C.
What I think Jones is
doing, in the largest version of
his project, is actually one of
the most wide-reaching and
ambitious unifying efforts that
I know of in contemporary
fiction.
So, this is not about the
fragmentation of grand
narrative.
It's about the enormous,
large-scale accumulation of
wholeness.
He is piecing a world together,
bit by bit by bit,
as he adds to his literary
oeuvre.
So, this is a vision of unity
that goes way beyond generic
boundaries.
Is it a short story?
Is it a novel?
This is something more like an
opus that Jones is building,
and, more importantly,
it's something that lives in
his mind very clearly.
These people,
these characters,
live in his mind.
There is no one doing what
Jones is doing today.
If there is something truly
postmodern, I would say Jones is
it.
He looks very different from
what comes before him,
in modernism,
and its ascendancy in the
mid-twentieth century.
He is making pretty dramatic
claims for the power of fiction,
for the power of narrative,
to put the world together,
but at the same time,
as I've noted,
acknowledges the very
difficulty of that project,
the very weakness that lies at
its heart.
And I think that's what,
for me, makes his work
extremely powerful,
that for all its ambition we're
never allowed to forget its
ambivalence.
That ambivalence is always
there on the surface,
and it's bodied forth in the
kinds of moral problems that
this novel dwells upon,
the question of how human love
can exist in slavery,
whether it can exist,
all its complicated forms,
what the forms of freedom look
like, how freedom can possibly
exist, how you build it,
how it can be maintained.
All these things are there in
an incredibly ambitious literary
form.
That's what Jones is doing that
nobody else is doing at this
moment.
So, I will stop there and we
will think about what Foer is
doing on--I will think about
what Foer is doing on
Monday.